Tiffany is with us in Charlotte North
Carolina hi Tiffany how are you hi Dave
I'm doing pretty well how are you better
than I deserve
what's up so I'm pretty new followers of
your approach and my question is should
I charge my mom for rent or a cost of
living due to a personal situation my
mom moved in with my husband and I and
we didn't we didn't have any
conversations around timeline or
financials at that time fast forward
five years to 10 years in a marriage and
she's still with us and we each work
full-time jobs
she offsets our childcare expense by
watching our kids for 20 hours a week he
does pay her portion of the phone bill
in her individual groceries but I know
she doesn't make a lot so I kind of feel
really guilty for even looking into
asking about paying for rent so we're
trying to get ahead of our finances and
just trying to take control of our
income and what is your household income
115 115 between the two of them how old
is your mom she's 53 and how old are
your kids I have a one-year-old and a
three-year-old okay and why is your mom
not functional and able to live it as a
standalone adult yeah that's a really
long answer that we don't have the time
for but she's trying to get on her feet
I'll say that she works for five years
why is she not functional and she got a
disability
she got a drug problem mhm yeah due to a
medical issue so she can still work is
just her medical condition limit what
type of work she can do so she has a
partial disability at least correct
correct all right so um number one you
know what what you didn't do before is
what we need to do now we need to we
need to extend this forecast into the
future a long way and that tells us how
much of a strain there is okay if she
left tomorrow and was on her own and was
functional
and was taking able to take care of
herself would you and your husband be
happy I would say yes because I think it
would alleviate some of the guilt that I
have and some of the pressure here okay
so in other words you're you're having a
live-in nanny is 90 percent for her 10
percent for you yeah okay so this is not
a good you know so if you look up 15
years from now and you're still sitting
here this is going to be really not fun
great yeah it's not going anywhere
positive okay in other words so what do
we need to do to get her on her feet
would be my question then what can we do
because over the last five years what
you've done hasn't worked she's not on
her feet great okay so what what has to
happen for her to be able to stand on
her own financially really I've tried to
have conversations regarding money or
plan or strategies and I kind of tiptoe
around them because I don't want to come
off disrespectful I don't want to feel
like I'm not disrespectful in their
house it's disrespectful that she lives
in your house and you've not had these
conversations because the goal here is
confused correct the goal was to help
her instead we have allowed her to
wallow in whatever it is she's wallowing
in she's not gotten better
you've not helped her all the comfort
and ease has harmed her is what I'm
hearing am I missing something no and
again she does help with the expense of
time no oh you're not oh your girl trips
you're 90 percent there for you and 90
percent there for her and 10 percent for
you so don't tell me how much she helps
you already said otherwise until you go
back into your guilt until you fell back
into your guilt trip again don't fall
into your guilt trip I'm trying to help
the lady she's 53 hang on my wife is 56
my wife would no more live with one of
my kids full-time then fly the moon and
what do you think would be the
way to approach a conversation well I
said I don't know what she's facing but
I guess what I wanted what I want is a
mom for her good where does she want to
be when she's 63 and when she's 73 where
did what does she want her life to look
like what level of dignity of carrying
her own and standing on her own I'd love
to be out on my own I just don't know
what came I must work on that what can I
do to help you do you need to take a
class do you need to do something you
need you need to not keep the kids all
the time so you're working more do you
need to get on a budget with the money
you do having coming in yes you need to
go through Financial Peace University
yes and so I want her I'm going to treat
her like she's a 28 year old living in
my basement okay what do I want to do I
want to launch them I want them to be
fly fly fly and leave the nest you
brought her in so she would have time to
heal and reset she's not resetting did I
miss something no not at all okay I'm
not again that's not being mean we're
not helping her by not helping her reset
I want her to reset so what we got to do
to reset and what's that look like and
if it takes a year and a half or two
years I'm okay take your time but doing
nothing and everybody walking around
acting like this is okay when it's not
okay day which is why you called me it
is that's just done out of guilt
and that's not healthy that's not good
for your kids that's not good for your
marriage it's not good for your mom your
mom needs the dignity of standing on her
own and winning again can you tell me
without embarrassing her or something
what the nature of her medical is um she
she has are a I don't know what that is
I'm sorry what rheumatoid arthritis okay
how about some days she's fine and
others it could take her out for the
entire day where she can't physically
get out of bed so let's pretend that we
start looking for a self-employed idea
that she can start a business where she
can make 30 or 40 thousand dollars a
year but some day she just can't work
but other days she get their work done
and can still pull off 30 or 40 grand a
year
what did she used to do years ago big
care ok in-home day care alright alright
and so what if she had a babysitting
service
she probably make thirty or forty doing
that and she was the babysitter she
would come to your home and babysit but
it was it was not a fixed day like you
have fixed days you is not daycare
replacement it's not nanny because those
people have to count on you but this is
if I'm available here's what I cost and
you have to check each week to see if
I'm available because we have to see how
my RA is they're doing okay and she you
know she works four or five days a week
when they are a a letter and I'm just
making this up on the spot okay but
that's the kind of thing where she can
control her zest and they make money and
have the dignity of being on her own and
maybe she babysits for you summon you
fair straight up but I think we need a
plan to help her get on our feet not
allow her to do nothing which is what's
going on now that's what I think you're
saying unless I'm missing something hold
on I'm going to send you a copy the book
boundaries which you're going to love
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]